hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're gonna be talking about the
past week that I've spent with a
Nintendo switch and I'm not gonna lie
it's actually exceeded my expectations
so I tend to send out a bunch of early
copies to youtubers and journalists as
usual as most game companies do and I'm
so grateful if it did send me one a week
ago I posted the unboxing and also a
setup video if you guys haven't seen
that you can feel free to check out the
links below and you can watch those
after this one of the things that I was
most surprised about is the portability
I mean yeah it's basically a tablet of
controllers but for me I play so much
intend oh 3ds i really don't leave home
without it
I love StreetPass that is one thing that
this is lacking currently I am hoping in
the Nintendo just has some sort of
miraculous announcement and launch day
maybe a few months later that it will
support StreetPass I don't want to have
to carry both like I want this to be my
new everything my friends and I we will
go to Disney honestly just a StreetPass
it's one of the most incredible places
to StreetPass because people from all
around the world to go there so not only
will you get locals but you get
worldwide mieze anyway that's just a
huge wish list for me notes moving on to
the games I know one of the huge things
as people are saying there's not a lot
of games and that's true there currently
isn't I guess what the amount of time
that I plan on putting it on a Zelda
there's nothing else that's gonna matter
I'm pretty sure I've probably put in at
least 25 hours possibly more I'm really
bad at estimating but I'm pretty sure
yesterday I probably put in 15 hours
because I didn't really leave the couch
and everywhere that I went I got I
played it and this can be verified by my
sister I even actually ended up staying
in my sister's house because I didn't
want to take the time to drive home guys
I'm starting to get worried about her
she won't go home because she was what
it felt like okay I also didn't post
videos for the past two days because
this is the reason Delta is really
really fun and I didn't think that I
would actually really get into it
I love open-world games and this is
extremely open-world the only bad part
for me is my gameplay style is I get
extremely sidetracked on side
anyone that asks me for help I'm like
yeah let me go hunt those deer for you
oh do you want me to help you out you've
got a problem I'm here for you I'm your
girl it's great the voice acting like I
just stopped I don't know I'm really
enjoying it and I'm so excited for you
guys to play it I thing the last Zelda
that I played was Majora's Mask on 3d s
I had my sister also filmed me out and
about to show you guys some scenarios of
what it's like to be out with the switch
[Music]
so nigh on Cena made this overly
dramatic video about the kickstand
showing you that it does fall over very
easily it isn't exactly the most sturdy
thing ever so definitely be careful but
like I mean this is with joy Kahn's on
it's like it's pretty salt look like you
do have to really push it it's kind of
like the size of a stick of gum this is
also where you're gonna be putting your
SD card in the past few nights I keep
telling myself one horse ride
just one more shrine just one more Tower
to unlock and then we're gonna go to
sleep but then something else happens
and then I find myself an hour two hours
later awake I also been playing a little
bit of one to switch I played with my
sister and my friend Matt and thankfully
I have a fairly decently sized office so
there's a lot of room for capture the
beach flag get a position you know just
right and then you hit oh my god you
guys are really going I was like wait a
minute
oh we were just gonna be milking cows so
you gotta like squeeze like you're
squeezing a nutter
and mills
look at your hands you milk and eating
hoies the father wipe other way testing
ours bend your legs tree yeah but no
there was definitely some some super
active games than that one too all in
all the portability is incredible
gameplay is awesome I just love being
able to take this thing everywhere one
of the things I'm looking forward to
other than more games is the accessories
one thing that I really want is a cool
stand probably some sort of case that
this can be set in that has like a
better little tripod this does make me a
little bit nervous I also need a really
good travel case I found one on Amazon I
also put a link in the description and I
will review some of those when I get
them in but this one looks really cool
it has like a nice grey pattern it looks
like everything's gonna fit quite nicely
but this fit pretty well in my backpack
that I already have I'm just really
concerned about the buttons because I
don't want those to get knocked around
if they're just loose in my bag so I do
want to have a protective cover for it
Anna my wish list is being able to buy
extra docks I'd love to have one
downstairs on my living room television
have one at my parents house so what
would me and my sister go home over the
holidays or come to visit we don't need
to bring the dock it will already be
there ready and waiting for us another
good thing is since this is USBC charger
which you do have to be careful because
not all USB C cables are made the same
make sure you're using certified USB C
cables that you know are not some
generic knockoff because it can
definitely fry your devices so you just
DC cables that I've been using are the
USBC ones that came with my pixel phone
and all of the Apple certified ones I
was even just charging this with my new
MacBook Pro laptop charger since the new
MacBook is pretty much predominantly USB
see that makes my life pretty simple
when it comes to charging and now we
just need the next iPhone to charge with
you SEC and everything it will be
awesome not sure if there's anything
else that I wanted to say I know a bunch
of people on Twitter wonders I know my
thoughts a lot of people in the comments
upset that I got one thing I don't
deserve it well you know what I'm sorry
I love Nintendo
okay I'm a huge digital fan and if you
don't believe it that's really not my
problem one of my favorite comments was
like that's the first time she's
probably ever touched a console and I
was like I probably have more consoles
on my desk then your age which I
actually only have Chu over there which
would make you two Xbox Playstation
actually I've got I've got some good
stuff hold on a second I've got rid of a
lot of my good consoles but I have saved
some of my favorites just hold on a
second let me bring something over for
you oh I've got some of my favourite
things
this was the r2d2 x360 I now have this
sitting on a display shelf because it's
so beautiful what I couldn't get myself
to get rid of it when I finally upgraded
Xbox one this is also my collector's
item it's the Nintendo 3ds
it's the NES version I haven't had in
264 sitting over here this is also the
c-3po a controller oh my god this is a
good time it's like showing pedal weight
by 64 oh hold on a second my most prized
possession it does not leave this box it
hasn't been opened since the day that I
got it
it is a signed Miyamoto Nintendo 3ds and
this was basically the greatest day of
my life
I watched him sign it I watched him draw
the little Mario face got it so it's so
incredible I might cry I was so excited
I need to get home to my parents house
because they still have my original
actually I still have it here too this
is for a later video that I have had
city health I just collected a bunch of
my amiibo either only half of the amiibo
like the rest of them are just fooling
around my house this is my childhood my
original NES is at home at my parents
house and I need to bring that back hold
on a second more amiibo on my desk more
amiibo Timmy and Tommy my sweet sweet
boys Oh God Zelda quick amiibo tip in a
Zelda if you missed the memo is you
could only use them once a day so
use them wisely you was hooked up down
here before and this is my choice of
decorating in my house those ones are
all missing because I took them down to
do my whole amiibo review goes down here
I'm a fan
what we have in here oh I don't know
just some more toys my life look I need
be good a portal but that's a whole
nother story I found more of my Mario
figures this is crazy
fall geez this is Rahul Xbox controllers
reside that what PlayStation we want to
look at like my book selection here that
I have on my coffee table mm-hmm 10 to
64 anthology Oh Larry you know playing
part saying that's classics nope
no man isn't a fan at all well thank you
guys so much for watching I apologize
for the small tangent but it is kind of
disheartening
day after day to hear people just
completely trying to tear you down and
tell you that you don't like something
that is basically your entire life's
passion it's the Internet
so I don't know I shouldn't really be
surprised since I've been doing this for
almost 11 years so to anyone who is
getting the switch let me know when you
get it let me know how you like it and I
look forward to hopefully playing some
multiplayer games I'm so excited for
Mario Kart that comes out in April Mario
Odyssey I mean I'm a huge Mario fan I
mean that's where my heart and soul is
so I definitely was upset that they
weren't launching with the Mario game
but I can wait for the new Mario Kart 8
remake you've got battle we've got a few
new cards and I'm gonna end this video
now so I can get back to doing what I
really want to do and that's play Zelda
and Animal Crossing game would be so
good I'm excited Thank You Nintendo I
love you guys and I'll see you later in
another video a video that I want to
make because I want to make it because
I'm talking about something I like
surprise surprise
[Music]